hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my youtube viewers al who
was asking about how to turn his
part-time business into a full-time
business so he wrote insane I have a
question for you I'm doing SEO internet
marketing consulting in addition to my
full-time job but I really want to do my
own business again what steps do you
recommend me to do this from a side
thing into a profitable full-time
business so I'll congrats on getting
this business started I'll often
recommend to new entrepreneurs to start
on a part-time basis so you still have
you no money committing from your job as
you build up your business it's more
important that they accept every day to
grow your business than to invest tons
of energy in the three months and then
shut the business down because you
haven't built up profitable base and you
haven't let the momentum grow for your
company so it's great to start part-time
what i would do is start approaching the
clients that you've already done some
work with and see if you can work out
some kind of monthly retainer system
because when you quit your job there's
that security that you got that money
coming in regularly so all of a sudden
that's gone so what you want to try to
do is line up some contracts where you
can get consistent money coming in
especially in the early days of a
business so you know you can pay the
rent and you know put food on the table
so at approach those companies and see
if there's anything you can do to make
it a monthly ongoing job with them and
think of other ways they might be able
to help them expand and grow their
business I then focus on over delivering
wowing them often as much value as you
can so they love you that they want to
talk about you tell their friends and
other business you know partners and
colleagues about you to help you get
some of that referral business coming in
customers are really busy they have a
lot of you know things that they have to
worry about so you really have to
over-deliver and provide so much more
extra value for them to want to talk
about you right you want to make sure
that you're on their radar map when
they're talking to other business owners
the next thing I do is try to become an
expert so it could be in your local area
so you might be a local SEO mark
expert try to get known to try to be
featured in the local papers and local
media local blogs and be seen as the guy
in your area who's the expert on SEO I
didn't also try to niech myself out to
pick up certain categories so maybe
you're working with lawyers professional
services or manufacturers or contractors
or car dealerships whatever it is find
the niche because there's so many guys
who are SEO consultants and internet
marketing guys so if you can show that
you're the best at what you do for a
certain category then if a new car
dealership is coming on and they want to
hire somebody well you're the guy to go
to for car dealerships so you'll know a
lot of their specific problems have no
packages that can tailor right to their
needs and you're much more likely to
land those clients so that would be my
advice for you good luck it sounds very
exciting if you guys like the video
please give it a thumbs up below and
also love to hear what your advice for
Al would be if you want to leave a
comment under this video and stay tuned
for next episode
you